nine years after qualifying as a midwife
sarah has had enough
she's handed in her notice worn out and
disillusioned by a role she once loved
we've changed her voice and name to
protect her identity
the job at the moment feels soul
destroying because the feeling that you
get when you leave the shift it's a
mixed emotion of exhaustion of sadness
and stress but not only that you feel
like you've finished your day's work and
you've not done a good job you've not
given the care that those families
deserve
she says staff shortages mean that too
often midwives are having to step into
roles they have no experience in and are
regularly expected to do the work of
three people
that compromises the care that you can
give to women and their families but
also it compromises you as a midwife in
terms of your professional
responsibilities
she's not the only one leaving the
profession the royal college of midwives
says there were 677
fewer midwives in england in april than
at the same time last year
that's on top of the existing shortage
of 2000 identified in
2021 but the government is aiming to
hire 1200 more midwives and 100
consultant obstetricians in a 95 million
pound recruitment drive
the midwives trade union thinks that
plan misses the point
we really welcome any new money into the
to into maternity services because boy
do they need it but actually we're in
the position at the moment of pouring
water into a leaky bucket it's not
recruiting midwives that is the problem
it's retaining the ones we've got
in november thousands of midwives took
to the streets in vigils warning
maternity care services were at breaking
point
since then it's only got worse
now there's growing momentum for strike
action
bertha sarah the decision has been made
she's no longer willing to stay in a job
where safety she says is being
compromised on a daily basis
emma birchley sky news